[Applauso]
conoscete questa ragazza
lei si chiama magliana manduca
e io non lo conoscevo almeno fino al 3
ottobre del 2003 quando da una
telefonata
mi annunciano che marianna è stata
ammazzata
lei era un geometra lavorava paragoni a
sé aveva un sogno quello di aprire un
proprio studio all'interno della sua
cittadina dove
aveva sempre vissuto e dove era nata
a un certo punto e contro la persona
durante la sua vita che gli scombussola
letteralmente tutto il suo essere donna
se ne innamora lo sposa con la famosa
suite in a non so se può non sentire
parlare di questa parola è un certo
punto si sposa e mette su famiglia
tre figli questi tre figli crescono
tra
botte violenze
sopraffazioni una persona che
praticamente era
stava cercando di ricostruirsi una vita
comincia a vedere il buio più totale
quindi dentro casa poi quindi non è che
gli arrivava da fuori questa cosa
decide a un certo punto della sua vita
di interrompere questa
questa strada che aveva preso
separandosi da questa persona è lì
inizia il vero calvario
ma rihanna in un anno
ha
fatto 12 denunce seguite da
12 ripeto ospedalieri dove ogni referto
mostrava le violenze questa persona
perpreta va tutti i giorni o tutte le
volte che la vedeva nei suoi confronti
a un certo punto il 3 ottobre
fa la cosa peggiore che un uomo fare
ammazzare la persona che dice di amare
la colpisce sei volte al petto
togliendogli riverire la vita
completamente non solo
finisce anche il padre con due
coltellate rimasto vivo per miracolo
naturalmente io tutto questo l'ho
scoperto la sera del 3 ottobre
attraverso la telefonata famosa
belly la mia vita è cambiata
completamente non
sinceramente non pensavo perché io non
conoscevo marianna non sapevo chi fosse
che vita faceva prima di quel giorno
scopro tutto andando in sicilia
scoprendo che c'erano tre bambini e che
questi bambini avrebbero fatto una
brutta fine se non ci fosse stato
qualcuno che li prendeva letteralmente
si riportava via
beh io ho avuto solo 4 ore insieme a mia
moglie per decidere
che cosa fare di questi bambini
sappiate che laggiù poi in quel momento
in quel preciso momento della loro vita
era già stata gestita da qualcuno e
devono andare in una casa famiglia
quindi voi pensate la perdita della
madre ammazzata dal padre il padre non
esiste più perché finisce in galera e
questi bambini soli ma alla fine dentro
una casa famiglia
al che io mia moglie non ce la siamo
sentita di far finta di niente
però c'era un altro problema noi avevamo
gia tre figli
quindi sapete che
crescere una famiglia così numerosa
è qualcosa di che va al di là delle
aspettative di ogni persona quindi non
ha idea di quello che ti può succede da
quel momento in avanti
beh vi posso dire che è stata
un'avventura pazzesca ma quella era solo
l'inizio
quindi non era la difficoltà di crescere
i bambini o di crescere treno di
crescere serio
di dargli da mangiare ridargli la scuola
la possibilità di studiare noi tutto
questo l'abbiamo fatto è successo
qualcos'altro nella mia
volontà era quella di scoprire perché
marianna era finita in quel modo perché
aveva denunciato 12 volte nessuno gli
aveva mai dato retta
l'ho scoperto molto in fretta c'era una
negligenza
pazzesca in quella procura quindi ho
deciso di fare causa allo stato
e per la prima volta
io adesso ve la faccio breve ma tutto
questo percorso è durato dieci anni
circa
in dieci anni mi sono fatto senigaglia
messina messina sinigaglia a volte anche
senza mangiare a volte senza dormire ma
non era importante quello l'importante
era dalla giustizia marianna perché
perché mariani aveva sofferto una vita
di pene ed ingiustizie e lo stato dal
bando nata completamente a un certo
punto decidiamo di fare questa causa
contro lo stato
e ci dicono che noi non potevamo fare
una causa contro lo stato per una
semplice ragione per una decorrenza dei
termini ma fortunatamente avevo due
legali
capaci di gestire una cosa del genere
siamo riusciti ad andare a processo
quindi condannano i giudici e finalmente
marianna cominciate nella giustizia ci
viene dato il risarcimento
con questo caesar cimento noi abbiamo
creato una struttura ricettiva dove oggi
noi ospitiamo parecchia gente e questo è
solo l'inizio
nel frattempo i bambini crescono c'è
l'esigenza di dargli qualcosa di più
quindi più stabilità più tranquillità
e diciamo che nel 2014 decidiamo di
adottarli definitivamente quindi
non solo avevamo fino a quel momento i
sette anni avevamo avuto
l'affido l'affido che un figlio sapete
può durare sei mesi due anni ma finisce
lì noi sette anni di affido dopodiché i
bambini passano e diventano figli i
nostri prendono il nostro cognome noi
mettiamo al corrente di tutta la
situazione i ragazzi e lo facciamo e
in un modo un po particolare
tutto è venuto fuori da
diciamo da una lite dove carmelo il più
grande aveva rubato delle figurine
quindi io lo porto a restituire queste
figurine e tornando a casa esplodo e il
racconto tutto quello che era successo
forse non è stata in modo migliore per
dire a loro che la mamma era stata
ammazzata dal padre ma io quello
conosciamo in quel momento è quello
fatto
però da lì la vita è cambiata
completamente i ragazzi hanno cominciato
a volerci ancora più bene di quello che
c'erano prima e quindi nel frattempo si
erano stati altri meccanismi noi avevamo
perso in appello perché la sappiate che
lo stato non si era fermato lì con
l'avvocatura dello stato decide di
andare in appello
e perdiamo ci richiedono indietro il
risarcimento
io minaccia di bruciare casa piuttosto
che ridarà indietro
finiamo in tv andiamo avanti ancora per
diverso tempo nel frattempo cosa succede
però che la rai decide di fare un film
sulla nostra storia
quindi nel 2018 casa mia viene
letteralmente invasa da persone mai
visto in vita mia
che
cominciano a farci parlare raccontare su
tutto quello che era capitato in fino a
quegli anni quindi viene fuori questa
bellissima fiction che è diventato un
film nel 2018 trasmesso il 6 dicembre
sulla rai
i nostri figli intitolato la che
racconta perfettamente o quasi
perfettamente la nostra storia
nel frattempo non ci bastava già quello
che avevamo quindi se i figli e film che
bimbi una serie di cose sappiate che poi
in tutto questo naturalmente io ho perso
il lavoro perché non c'era c'è la crisi
quindi io avevo un attività edile la
chiudo perché un certo punto non si
poteva più andare avanti pagare solo
esclusivamente le tasse senza mai
lavorare
capire che con sé i figli non era facile
giusto per non farci mancare nulla
decidiamo di aprire
l'associazione insieme a marianna onlus
che si occupa esclusivamente
di portare formazione informazione
all'interno degli istituti perché questa
scelta perché già di associazioni che
proteggono le donne e che comunque si
mettono in campo con
tantissimi strumenti e forse anche
meglio di noi sotto tanti punti di vista
e che aiutano le donne ce ne sono
tantissime noi volevamo fare qualcosa di
più volevamo entrare nella testa delle
persone e far capire che la nostra
cultura la cultura che attualmente c'è
oggi nel 2021 è sbagliata
e inutile che noi
facciamo qualcosa senza avere risultato
quindi abbiamo detto il nostro compito è
andare nelle scuole portare alla cultura
del rispetto l'educazione
all'interno degli istituti attraverso i
ragazzi che i ragazzi sono
è la le prime persone a cui rivolgersi
sono quelli che
assorbono capiscono e guardate più di
quello che uno possa immaginare
i risultati migliori li abbiamo avuti
proprio con loro e non con gli adulti
gli adulti non si fanno prendere dai
discorsi non ascoltano fanno finta di
niente
quindi l'educazione al rispetto
era la nostra materia principale abbiamo
fatto tanti
tanti convegni abbiamo radunato
circa 300 400 ragazzi a cui rivolgevamo
tutte le nostre perplessità e cos'è
attraverso naturalmente dei percorsi per
e ci sono stati si college i carabinieri
polizia avvocati
e l'associazione a un certo punto ha
sentito il dovere di creare qualcosa di
diverso
ve la presento questa è la cassetta del
pronto soccorso dove noi dentro abbiamo
radunato
una serie di cose
le forbici cerotti il forno scopio che
importantissimo cosa accade quando una
vittima valli va a denunciare il proprio
carnefice o la persona che comunque
la maltratta
il primo impatto
ce l'ha con le forze dell'ordine voi
sapete che è già difficile che una
ragazza possa andare a denunciare dal
momento in cui lo fa si trova davanti
delle persone che non sanno ascoltare
cioè non hanno la formazione adeguata
per poter ricevere tutto il dolore che
questa ragazza o questa donna porta lì
da loro
quindi noi abbiamo pensato di fare che
cosa di mettere una serie d
nozioni di leggi
lavorate naturalmente pensate da
psicologi avvocati
e polizia sono racchiuse tutte qua
dentro
l'antidolorifico
che la medicina che
con l'ascolto col parlare attraverso gli
psicologi ti porta a capire dove ti
sbagliavi e dove tu non devi più
sbagliare
le forbici il taglio direttamente il
taglio diretto con la cole carnefice
questa importantissima
perché ti dà finalmente la dimensione in
cui vivi e ti fa capire quanto tu sei
importante
perché la sua maggioranza delle volte
succede questo tagli ma poi ritorna
indietro per paura di ritorsioni di
cattiveria nei confronti
quindi rinunci toglie e elimini la
denuncia e ritorno e punto e daccapo
questo non deve mai accadere l'avana
quando e denuncia deve andare avanti per
il suo percorso senza paura perché
comunque ci sono gli aiuti e sostegni
quindi abbiamo creato questa cosa io
sono qui per oggi non solo per
raccontare la mia storia
che ormai la conoscono in tutta italia
perché tra giornali tv
mi sono molto esposto a volte anche
senza il consenso dei miei figli
però ho un dovere tutto quello che io ho
fatto fino ad oggi ho il dovere di
divulgarlo a tutti perché è importante
perché la gente possa capire esattamente
chi dimensioni a questa fase culturale
dei nostri anni perché questa è una
questione di cultura
non si deve pensare che è un fenomeno
perché qui di fenomeni non c'è nulla qui
gli unici fenomeni sono gli uomini che
decidono
all'improvviso
dopo che sono stati lasciati di
ammazzare le proprie donne questo non
deve più accadere oggi mio messaggio è
questo noi vogliamo portare questa
cassetta del pronto soccorso in tutti i
luoghi dove c'è bisogno dalle scuole
alle forze dell'ordine
dove c'è necessità di capire come
funziona tutto il meccanismo perché
all'interno c'è la costituzione c'è
codice tutto il meglio del codice rosso
dove dà l'idea di come si può gestire
una persona che viene a chiederti aiuto
e quindi
avere la capacità di dare una risposta a
questa ragazza o a questa donna perché
sapete
a settembre sulla volte in dieci giorni
11 donne e
l'asta maggioranza dei casi non avevo
neanche denunciato sapete perché non
denunciano per vergogna perché hanno
paura
perché si sentono diverse e invece
questo che dobbiamo evitare e lo
facciamo attraverso uno strumento del
genere perché se la gente è formata se
la gente capisce quando c'è una donna
che sta chiedendo aiuto anche tra di voi
se c'è qualcuno che ha capito come
funziona il meccanismo può aiutare
questa donna a denunciare è una volta
che si attiva tutto il meccanismo la
donna può essere salvata
e non bisogna aver paura di mettersi in
mezzo perché questo è un messaggio che
voglio lanciare oggi è naturalmente ho
bisogno del vostro aiuto in tutto questo
e finisco dicendo
che nessuna donna ha bisogno di aiuto
non serve aiutare le donne chi deve
essere date sono gli uomini perché sono
gli uomini che sono violenti grazie
mille
[Applauso]